ich habe am 10 dezember einen beitrag in
der spätschicht comedy bühne gemacht vom
swr mit wenigen und 80er jahren
zusammenarbeite die redaktion kann den
sekt hat ihn abgesegnet hat ihn gesehen
so dann komme ich zur aufzeichnung fünf
minuten sonderauszeichnung konfrontieren
möchte dass der moderator schröder damit
nicht einverstanden ist und werden wird
er ist überhaupt nicht meiner meinung in
der anmoderation das ist erstmalig und
einmalig in der kabarett oder überhaupt
tv-geschichte
dann habe ich das trotzdem gemacht dann
hat ist es auffällig geworden da
matthias meißner von der taz hat es
losgetreten und ging 1 ein sturm durch
die presse mit schwulen und lisa fitz
und liegt weiter die rede war von 5000
toten das war mittel unglücklich kann
nur geld an die nachher aber erläutern
wie ich dazu gekommen
dann ging es los und dann hat man das ja
so eine meinungsfreiheit beim swr
verteidigt und dann hat der
programmdirektor clemens bratzler hat
sich unter medialem druck gefühlt und
hat verlautbaren lassen die zahlen von
lisa fitz sind nachweislich falsch dass
wir so was aber juristisch anfechtbar
weil er gar keine nachweislich richtigen
zahlen liefern kann der swr bis dato
auch nicht und dann hat es eskaliert und
unter diesen in der branche
rechtsanwaltes prüfen lassen weil dort
alcoa und der sagt ja es ist anfechtbar
dann stand es im raum die stellen so die
gespannter und dann hat die redaktion
wir wollten aber weitermachen und der
schluss war dass die redaktion dann
sonne ich nenne es mal so würden sich
das verbieten quellen schikane für
nächsten text gemacht haben das stimmt
nicht und so geht's nicht und das gibt
es nicht und wir können auch nicht mehr
telefonieren weil der rechtsanwalt hängt
im raum wer gegen bratzel als äußerer
wiegen und dann habe ich sie kenne so
kann ich nicht arbeiten fazit das hätte
man anders regeln müssen und für mich
war das ein vertrauensbruch weil
loyalität geht anders jetzt hat der swr
zu ihnen aber gesagt man hätte gerne mit
ihnen weiter gemacht es war sozusagen
der schritt kam nicht vom swr aus und
bei den zahlen die sie ansprechen der
vorwurf was die im stehen oder im toten
angeht diese quelle bezieht sich auf
einen man kann sagen rechts
verschwörerischen blog wo jetzt keine
tanzen zu sehen sind das
ist die 5000 stammen von einer
französischen rechtsextremist hat im
europäischen parlament virginie
ich hab da muss man auch mal schauen wie
gut die sind die zahlen wie das gekommen
das ist ein entschließungsantrag dass
wir vom eu parlament und ich bin
tatsächlich also nicht reingefallen
wieder entschließungsantrag wurde
tatsächlich gestellt von der vision ist
was sie versäumt haben nach zu googeln
dass sie wurden der for national ist hat
man mir vorwerfen beträgt musste ich
nicht getan also soweit sie hat aber
ihre zahlen von der immer von
europäischen arzneimittelagentur und
voller guter wünsche lins heißt nicht
glaube ich sind teil davon daher hat sie
nicht von irgendeinem blog wo irgend wer
die impfschäden schreibt sondern daher
hat sie ihre zahlen ich hab dann
recherchieren lassen
was ich versäumt habe ich jetzt sagen
also verdachtsfälle ja das war aber dass
sowas bespricht man den sender unter hat
nicht ganz deutschland für ein großer
unterschied verdachtsfälle oder tut aber
dann hätte man mich geholt sagt frau
facts was haben wir da können wir das
und so weiter reden ich mit dem
jobverlust wurde herzlich mich im
mittelpunkt stellen vor dass man das und
dann habe ich inzwischen auf eigene
kosten recherchieren lassen und zwar vom
kck der hammer 20 jahre monitor hat für
die zdf anstalt jahre lang recherchiert
und der hat herausgefunden es kam ich
kommt demnächst auf meiner webseite
herbst versprochen dass mit hoher und
höchster wahrscheinlichkeit
5000 mindestens toten durch impfschäden
zu beklagen sind und ziemlich mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit auch große starke
nebenwirkungen und ist jetzt aber bin
ich auf eine auf einem ohr ankommende
recherche das in seine quellen wasser
das zufällig also wenn man ja ja das
ständige diese ganzen dieses robert koch
das thema dieses elends das sind die
ganze nicht gab es aber das ist okay und
jetzt wir können jetzt schwierig über
eine reserve hält noch nicht
veröffentlicht und ist deswegen muss man
ganz vorsichtig sein noch bei der zahl
von 14 jahre aus unserer sicht das ist
ja auch schwierig weil man kommt wenn
wenn sie recherchieren dann kommen sie
auf die 700 die unterseite von der immer
in medizinischen englisch recherchen
sind wie schwierig das kennen wir
journalisten frau im krankenhaus wie
nehmen sie das war die frage wie in da
möchte ich mal darauf zurück das war der
ursprung der debatte in
öffentlich-rechtlichen talkshows in
diesem fall oder kabarettisten sendung
damit unterschiedlichen meinungen
umgegangen wird also wir reden jetzt
hier nicht über unterschiedliche meinung
sondern über sie haben ja sagt das war
in dem fall eine falsche tatsache die
sie da vorgetragen haben und sie hätten
sich dafür gern entschuldigt in
zusammenarbeit mit dem sender also hab
ich das wahrgenommen also ich glaube
dass wir auch grundsätzlich gar nicht
der meinung waren dass da jetzt irgend
wie der mund verboten wurde sondern sie
haben ja gesagt man hätte das im vorfeld
klären müssen ist es mir auch auffallen
müssen dass da ein fehler unterlaufen
ist und ich hätte mich dafür
entschuldigt so habe ich jetzt ihre
sendung wurde grenze ltte nur der goalie
der ausbildung hat die chance ja aber in
der sendung wahlarena die
tatsachenbehauptung deshalb nichts
grundsätzlich erstmal in ordnung an
diesem montag zu nehmen und dann haben
sie ja gesagt mediatheken genau in der
mediothek und dann haben sie ja gesagt
sie möchten in zukunft nicht mehr mit
ihm zusammenarbeiten und jetzt hab ich
mal so ein bisschen recherchiert was
wieso teilweise als kabarettistin so
gesagt habe mal sie haben zum beispiel
gesagt gegenüber von russia today
es ging um andere kabarettisten seinen
systemimmanente hofnarren viele werden
in deutschland einer demokratischen
diktatur der parteien und ich finde wenn
man so krasse sachen sagt dann finde ich
komisch wenn man dann in der kritik
steht dass man dann sagt der sender
hätte mir emotional mehr zur seite
stehen müssten deshalb ich finde wenn
man so krasse aussagen macht dann muss
man auch auf der anderen seite dann wenn
man meine falsche tatsachenbehauptung im
raum gestellt hat muss man dazu stehen
muss man sagen das tut mir leid und ich
entschuldige mich und ich werde in
zukunft meine kleine besser
recherchieren ja das können sie ja
finden wenn ich die zeit frau lehrerin
aber ich das ist so die moralismus dem
ich annehme wälder weil damit unter
clemens bratzler hat verteilt die zahlen
sind nachweislich falsch und das kann ja
nicht sagen das können sie auch nicht
sagen das kann niemand sagen sie sind
nicht nachweislich falsch aber auch
nicht richtig muss man nein weil sie
sind nicht nachweislich falsch weil die
richtigen gar nicht nachweisbar sind
rechts fall juristisch angreifbar also
hätte wäre den bratzler kein zacken aus
der krone gebrochen wenn er nicht mehr
angerufen hätte gesagt fitz können wir
uns mal regeln weil ganz falsch so
falsch dass du unser fokus hat sich dann
verstiegen frau fitz lügt bewusstsein
wie gedacht jetzt hausherren als
ungewöhnlich das gewünscht hätte ich mir
dass das da ist er auch der herr von und
zu chef bei mir kommt sagt was ist da
gelaufen das ist nicht gut dann hätten
wir das geredet dann hätten wir eine
gemeinsame ohne dass das selber
irgendwas verbreitet was dann zum halali
praest und mich in ganz deutschland als
lügnerin schmugglerin unglaubwürdige
tante was er gar nicht so stimmt neben
der gemeinsamen erklärung abgegeben ich
lese es nicht ich bin da einer tante
aufgesessen die mir nicht von der
politik herr recht ist und ich möchte es
gern wir schneiden den beitrag ich würde
es anders formulieren ich würde sagen
verdachtsfälle nun hätten wir gemeinsam
die kuh vom eis geholt und gekündigt
habe ich aber noch nicht deswegen
sondern weil dann die arbeit nachdem das
gelaufen ich habe dann sagt ich mache
nichts
rechtliches ich will nur einfach jetzt
raus weil mir die arbeit dann so
erschwert wurde da drin ja sie haben
aber da gesagt aber sonst reich und der
begriff reich ist aber schon belastet
das können wir so nicht sagen und dann
haben sie gesagt chef besseres da dessen
reich ist grenzenlos sie können das
besser nicht unterstellt und dann ging's
rücken aber gesagt jetzt kennt mich ja
ich muss also ich muss mal fest wir
bekennen
aber du hast einen fehler gemacht du
hast nämlich die 5000 ins spiel gebracht
ohne zu wissen woher sie stammen und sie
stammt doch da muss auch schon damals
wusstest du doch wusstest du nicht da wo
wir sie brauchen eine rechtsextreme hast
du musst nicht nicht so das hast du dann
erkannt und dann hast du ja wenn ich das
gewusst hätte hätte ich nicht ich immer
zähle jetzt ist nicht gesagt und dann
nachdem du das sozusagen eingeräumt dass
das ein fehler war hast du das
recherchieren in auftrag gegeben und
jetzt sagst du eben auch jetzt steht
noch nicht fest wie viele in wahrheit an
omikron
corona gestorben sind in europa das
heißt du führst ein rennen gegen den
sender das so gar nicht gewinnen kannst
auch nicht gegen die öffentlichkeit
gegen große teile der öffentlichkeit da
musst du einfach sagen wenn ich das
gewusst hätte ich es nicht gemacht hat
sich dagegen haus zu holen hat sich da
etwas verändert und sind sozusagen bei
öffentlich rechtlichen aber auch
insgesamt bei der allianz ist derart in
weiten teilen was er sagen wollte mir
ist das dreimal passiert bei öffentlich
rechtlichen sendern da habe ich nicht so
was gemacht habe ich nicht mit zahlen
hantiert sondern hat eine abweichende
meinung vertreten was war das für eine
beispielsweise habe ich gesagt dass ich
zweig für verfassungswidrig halten weil
es einen großen teil der menschen
nämlich in ungeimpften ihre rechte nimmt
und zwar auf verordnungs basis so dass
es gar kein ja meiner meinung nach ist
ihr dann passiert also dann bin ich dann
bin ich zweimal ausgeladen worden und
einmal ist ein text von mir verschwunden
aber wie hat man das begründet hat man
nicht anders hat man anders begründet
weil ich als journalist bin da will man
sich ja nicht in die falle begeben mir
zu sagen also einmal ist das thema einer
sendung verändert worden kurz sehr
kurzfristig zum anderen mal hat man mir
jetzt sagt ich mache etwas einfach waren
kunstvolle formulierung gesagt wenn ich
in die sendung käme um über mein buch zu
reden müsste man ja mit mir eigentlich
auch nach dem was ich jetzt gesagt hätte
über corona reden das aber nicht der
gegenstand der sendung und deshalb könne
man mich nicht einladen zu überzeugen
sicher war dass ich hätte
das war der sage ich jetzt mal die
einzige ausnahme das war der bayerische
rundfunk der kuriose geschichte da habe
ich auch nur gelacht aber da hat sich
jemand richtig mühe gegeben das
kunstvoll zu erkennen zu geben worum es
in wahrheit geht die beiden anderen male
waren bei einem noch viel größeren
sender und das sage ich jetzt nicht weil
ich den leuten mit denen ich dazu tun
hatte nicht schaden will die haben mir
auch hinweise gegeben wo ich einmal
ausgeladen worden bin und einmal etwas
was ich gesagt habe aus einem bestimmten
archiv verschwunden es beziehungsweise
nicht eingewandert ist das ist schon auf
also es gibt kein rückhalt schon aus
seiner sicht absolut bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen sendern wird werden die
geländer der meinungsfreiheit immer
näher heran gezogen an den pfad und
jetzt ist es unter anderem auch durch
die debatte über die sinnhaftigkeit des
impfens und von 2g an der zeit damit
schluss zu machen bevor man wieder nimmt
sie das war ganz kurz gibt ist die
problematik dass in der öffentlichkeit
leute weil sie eine andere meinung
vertreten nicht mehr eingeladen werden
ich glaube auch dass hierbei live show
nicht eingeladen wurden weil sie zu
langweilig waren oder die meinung
vertreten haben gesagt haben das passt
nicht in die sendung also ich glaube
jetzt ist es wichtig gerade übrigens
immer öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk
dass wir die vielfalt von meinungen
präsentieren ich finde das ist sehr sehr
wichtig glaubt darum können uns alle
einigen ich glaube aber muss ebenso eine
unterscheidung nach inzwischen was ist
meinung was ist was ist eine falsche
bahn baut und ich glaube das ist sehr
wichtig dass wir gemeinsam auch darüber
sprechen ich kenne jetzt die beiträge
nicht über diese gesprochen haben und
ich kenne auch jetzt jeden fall nicht im
konkreten details so gut wie sie in
kärnten im fall hatte ich noch keinen
gegeben das aber da haben die akw aber
ich glaube schon dass ich so dass alle
flüge ich finde es gibt sehr viele
menschen so viele wie seit sehr langer
zeit nicht mehr die in deutschland sagen
ich habe das gefühl ich kann meine
meinung nicht mehr sagen und ich finde
das ist ein großes problem ich finde wir
müssen gemeinsam daran arbeiten dass das
sich dass die zahlen sich da deutlich
verringern auf der anderen seite wünsche
ich mir gerade von denen die sehr stark
mit ihrer meinung nach außen gehen und
so weiter dann auch einen gewissen
panzer zu sagen ich halte auch dann
gegenmeinung aus ja ich habe dafür
braucht man nur einen satz wenn man das
tut das hier habe ich mehrfach gesagt
ist ein reich der freiheit hier darf
jeder der hier eingeladen wird seine
meinung zu sagen zu einem thema das er
sich selber aussucht aber wenn das so
ist und wir hier in verschiedener
hinsicht völlig frei reden brauchen wir
auch verbündete in der politik die das
aufnehmen und verteidigen und die kann
ich nicht sehen denn eine verteidigerin
der meinungsfreiheit aus dem hut leser
halten sache aus das sieht man ja dass
wir jetzt ganz oder abschluss denn dann
müssen langsam thema gehen was verband
man bewirkt zu machen hat auch mich
hingeschmissen weil frau witzes
beleidigt ist oder so sondern weil ich
unter den umständen mit der redaktion
aber dieser winter möchte man immer aber
überlegen welches meiner